die Internationale Raumstation wird ihr
Ende lange kommen sehen ihr Abstieg
beginnt zwischen Ende 2026 und Anfang
2028 2013 soll der letzte Mensch die ISS
verlassen im Januar 2031 wird die
Station dann so tief abgesenkt dass die
Reibung der Atmosphäre sie immer weiter
aufheizt und die Station schlussendlich
zerbricht was nicht verglüht findet sein
kaltes einsames Grab im point Nimo dem
Ort im Pazifik der weiter von jeder
Landmasse entfernt ist als jeder andere
Punkt auf der Erde so lautet zumindest
der Plan 30 Jahre lang diente die ISS
als Symbol für internationale
Zusammenarbeit für Forschung und
Entwicklung am Limit aber was kommt
danach
[Musik]
gleich mehrere neue Raumstationen sollen
die ISS als Forschungslabor im erdnahen
Orbit ablösen was die können wer sie
betreibt und ob mit der ISS auch die
internationale Zusammenarbeit versenkt
wird genau darum geht es jetzt die
Assassin's
nations life
die ISS ist ein Projekt der
amerikanischen NASA der europäischen ESA
der japanischen yaksa der kanadischen
CSA und rosskosmos also Russland an Bord
der ISS wurden und werden mehrere
tausend Experimente durchgeführt die die
Wissenschaft weiter nach vorne gebracht
haben auch der Bau und der Betrieb der
ISS hat viele Innovationen
hervorgebracht die NASA hat hierzu mal
ein sehr spannendes man muss es fast
schon buchen nennen herausgebracht mit
hunderten Seiten über die verschiedenen
Innovationen die wir der ISS zu
verdanken haben und bis sie ausgemustert
wird soll sie sogar noch produktiver
werden als bisher
die Zusammenarbeit droht allerdings
jetzt schon zu zerbrechen was Kosmos
hatte letztes Jahr laut über einen
Ausstieg nachgedacht und wegen des
ukrainekriegs ist das wohl
unwahrscheinlich dass sie über 2024
hinaus dabei bleiben auch wenn NASA und
rosskosmos nun doch wieder gemeinsame
Flüge Unternehmen nach dem Putin den
Chef von rosskosmos ausgetauscht hat die
drei Kosmonauten die derzeit an Bord
sind hatten bei ihrer Ankunft in märz
mit ihren gelb-blauen Anzügen für
Aufruhr gesorgt denn die erinnerten sehr
an die ukrainische Flagge den
Zusammenhang stritten sie erstmal ab
spätestens seit sie an Bord der ISS
Fotos mit den Flaggen der ukrainischen
pro russischen Separatisten gemacht
haben ist aber klar Russland missbraucht
auch die ISS für seine Kriegspropaganda
rosskosmos verkündeten auch an einer
eigenen Raumstation zu bauen die 2025
oder 2026 starten sollen die Station
heißt Ross Russian orbitel service
station und wird vermutlich nur bei
Bedarf bemannt werden es befinden sich
zwar noch mehr Details dazu im Internet
aber die Schwellen wirken auf uns nicht
besonders zuverlässig deswegen lassen
wir das jetzt mal aus Ende Juli da
hatten wir dieses Video hier eigentlich
schon abgedreht hat rosskosmos noch
einmal für Verwirrung gesorgt und zwar
hat der neue Generaldirektor Yuri Bury
soft wieder gesagt Russland würde 2024
aus dem iss-projekt Aussteigen sollten
die Russen tatsächlich aussteigen dann
wäre die ISS nicht mehr einsatzbereit
denn es sind die russischen
Antriebssysteme die die Station im Orbit
halten aber schon am nächsten Tag wurde
das von der NASA wieder eingeordnet es
gäbe keine Hinweise darauf dass Russland
wirklich aus dem Projekt aussteigen
wolle auf keiner Ebene und rosskosmos
selber veröffentlichte dann auch noch
ein Interview mit dem flight Director
der geplanten russischen Raumstation der
Ross dass sie nicht aus dem iss-projekt
Aussteigen wollen bis die Ross voll
operabel sei und das wäre frühestens
2028 der Fall auf einer
militärausstellung wurde jetzt übrigens
ein Modell der Ross gezeigt und sie wird
tatsächlich größer als bisher gedacht
anscheinend soll sie bis 2030 aus vier
Modulen bestehen
insgesamt ist die Kommunikation von
rosskosmos nicht so konsistent falls
also nächste Woche schon wieder was
anderes hören solltet ist nicht unsere
Schuld und hat wahrscheinlich auch
Propaganda Gründe was aber sicher ist
russland will in Zukunft mehr mit China
zusammenarbeiten
Bücher über die Zukunft der Raumfahrt
gibt es unzählig viele an den würdet ihr
wahrscheinlich noch lesen wenn bereits
die erste internationale maßstation
gebaut ist darauf müsst ihr allerdings
gar nicht warten dank des heutigen
Sponsors blinkist liefert euch 15
minütige Text oder Mini Hörbücher
sozusagen zu insgesamt über 5.500
Sachbüchern und Podcast so zum Beispiel
auch das Buch in passuit auf die unknown
von ihnen Stewart in dem es um 17
bahnbrechende Formeln aus Mathematik und
Physik geht die unser heutiges
Verständnis der Welt und des Universums
erst möglich gemacht haben ich und die
meisten bei uns im Team nutzen blinkist
regelmäßig weil es einfach mega viel
Zeit spart und man überall und jederzeit
was neues lernen kann per blinkist
Connect das ist neu könnt ihr jetzt auch
einfach eine weitere Person in euer Abo
einladen und die kann dann auch auf das
gesamte Angebot zugreifen und bekommt
sogar einen eigenen Account so könnt ihr
ganz einfach und offiziell auch einen
Account sharen wenn ihr euch jetzt
blinkist Premium holt dann könnt ihr
komplett kostenlos 7 sagen alle Bücher
auf blinkes testen und jederzeit
kündigen falls ihr dann genauso huckt
seid wie ich könnt ihr auf
blinkes.de/drogsen 25% Rabatt auf ein
Jahresabo blinkes Premium bekommen der
erste Link unten in der
Videobeschreibung ihr kennts danke an
blinkist für die Unterstützung und die
gesparte Zeit bei uns in der Recherche
und jetzt geht's zurück ins All
weil die USA die Zusammenarbeit mit den
Chinesen auf der ISS und in der
Raumfahrt generell ablehnen haben die in
ihre eigene Raumstation gebaut wissen
viele gar nicht aber die ISS ist schon
seit april 2021 nicht mehr die einzige
Station im erdnahen Orbit und seit Juni
2021 ist die chinesische Station auch
bemannt allerdings ist sie mit der rund
100 Meter langen iss nicht wirklich zu
vergleichen zu dem Basismodul hier am he
das mit ca 16,5 Metern Länge etwa so
lang ist wie das älteste iss Modul mit
lebenserhaltungssystemen kam Ende Juli
noch das erste von zwei geplanten
forschungsmodulen hinzu wenn das zweite
Modul im Oktober angedockt ist ist die
Station erst einmal vollständig weitere
Erweiterungen sind wohl nicht geplant
Forschung und Bildung sind die
wichtigsten Aufgaben der Station aber
auch über space Tourismus denkt man in
China nach ein internationales habe in
dem forschen aus der ganzen Welt
zusammenarbeiten wird die chinesische
Raumstation aber ganz sicher nicht
neben den Russen kann sich aber auch die
europäische Weltraumagentur ESA
vorstellen an Bord der chinesischen
Raumstation wissenschaftliche
Experimente durchzuführen allerdings
soll die Station Mitte der 2030er Jahre
schon wieder ausgemustert werden was
macht die ESA also wenn weder die ISS
noch die chinesische Raumstation für die
Forschung zur Verfügung stehen die ESA
selbst hält sich aus dem Betrieb von
bemannten Raumschiffen und Raumstationen
heraus sie konzentrieren sich
stattdessen eher auf Projekte wie das
europäische GPS Galileo das Kopernikus
Satellitenprogramm zu Erdbeobachtung
oder die Sonde Solar Orbiter die Bilder
von der Sonne aus nie dagewesener Nähe
macht mit Exo Mars brachte die ESA einen
Satelliten in den Orbit um den Mars
wichtiger Partner bei der Exo
Mars-Mission ist aber Russland also
bleibt wegen des Ukraine Kriegs der
dazugehörige erste europäische Mars
Rover erstmal auf der Erde über die
Zukunftspläne der ESA haben wir letztes
Jahr mit Thomas Reiter gesprochen dem
Berater des Generaldirektors der ESA
schaut euch gerne mal dieses Video hier
an das lohnt sich aber zurück zu den
Raumstationen
statt eine Raumstation zu bauen möchte
die esaführung gerne in die private
Raumfahrt investieren dazu gehören auch
kommerzielle Raumstationen in dieser
Hinsicht ist die NASA der Isar
allerdings schon weit voraus wie will
sich nämlich um Stationen im erdnahen
Orbit möglichst bald nicht mehr selbst
kümmern müssen die NASA richtete
deswegen letztes Jahr einen Wettbewerb
aus in dem sich Privatfirmen um
Förderung bewerben konnten Anfang des
Jahres hat die NASA verkündet drei Teams
beim Aufbau von kommerziellen
Raumstationen zu fördern alle drei
Stationen sollen modular erweiterbar
sein und eine Infrastruktur für
Forschung und Entwicklung anbieten
außerdem an dass ihre Station Bereiche
mit künstlicher Schwerkraft haben wird
und auch dem tourismusoffen stehen soll
die Raumstation starlab von nanorex
Voyager space und logite beheimatet den
George Washington Cover Science Park
zwei labormodule für biologische
Forschung und Materialforschung ein
Modul für die Pflanzenzucht und eine
Werkstatt die Station umfasst 340
Kubikmeter wohnen und Arbeitsraum der
Clou die Station ist aufblasbar trotz
der Größe soll sie aber nur vier
Personen permanent beherbergen starlab
ist auch die einzige Station mit einem
Fest versprochenen Launch-Termin 2027
wird die Station von Blue Origin und
Sierra space heißen sie soll ein
Businesspark für alle werden was auch
immer das heißt schon Ende dieses
Jahrzehnts sollen die Besucher forschen
und Produkte entwickeln können und sie
sollen diese Produkte auch dort
herstellen können Medienmacher können
dort Filme drehen das hat man ja auf der
SS auch schon mal gemacht unser Video
dazu hier und Urlauber mit dem nötigen
Kleingeld sind auch willkommen die
Betreiber wollen alle notwendigen
Dienstleistungen anbieten vom Transport
mit wieder endbaren Raketen über
Logistik bis zur Unterstützung bei
technischen Entwicklungen und sogar
Außenmissionen mit 830 Kubikmeter wird
orbitel Reef nur etwas kleiner sein als
die ISS und kann zehn Personen
unterbringen außerdem soll die Station
große Fenster bekommen die raumfahrende
Nationen versprechen sich von den
kommerziellen Anbietern vor allem mehr
Effizienz und niedrigere Preise als sie
selbst beim Betrieb der ISS erzielen
konnten außerdem müssen sie sich dann ja
nicht mehr selbst um die Unterhaltung
der Infrastruktur für transportforschung
und Entwicklung und die ganze
Astronauten Ausbildung im erdnahen Orbit
kümmern stattdessen kaufen Sie diese
Leistungen einfach ein so können sich
NASA ESA und Co auf den nächsten Schritt
der Weltraum Erkundung konzentrieren
raumbasen auf dem Mond die NASA will mit
dem artemis-projekt eine feste Präsenz
auf dem Mond aufbauen das Projekt
beinhaltet auch eine kleine Station im
Orbit um den Mond Artemis ist eine mega
spannende Mission deshalb haben wir das
ja schon eine ganze Video Reihe gemacht
und die könnt euch hier anschauen als
Antwort auf die artemismissionen wollen
die Russen und Chinesen scheinbar
bereits 27 mit dem Bau ihrer eigenen
permanenten unbemannten Mondbasis
beginnen 8 Jahre früher als ursprünglich
angekündigt aber das ist ein Thema für
ein anderes Video
das Ende der ISS läutet eine neue R1 die
mindestens drei geplanten kommerziellen
Stationen werden mehr Möglichkeiten
bieten als die ISS heute und Sie werden
mehr starten mehr Firmen und mehr
Menschen den Zugang zum erdnern Orbit
erlauben als jemals zuvor sie dienen mit
ihren Dienstleistungen auch als
Sprungbrett für die raumfahrenden
Nationen die weiter in den Weltraum
vordringen wollen erst zum Mond und
schließlich zum Mars wenn sie denn
gebaut werden und wenn sie es bis in den
Orbit schaffen es wäre nicht die ersten
von der NASA finanzierten Projekte die
dann von privaten Firmen verschleppt
werden auch weiterhin werden sich die
verschiedenen Staaten für die
raumerkundung zusammenschließen
allerdings glaube ich dass diese
Kooperationen deutlich kleiner und
politisch weniger symbolträchtig sein
werden und das finde ich sehr schade
aber die neuen Konstellationen
reflektieren eben auch die sich
verändernden geopolitischen Verhältnisse
auf der Erde gehen wir also technisch
einige Schritte nach vorne aber was
internationale Zusammenarbeit angeht
einige zurück das kann man final erst
bewerten alles soweit ist ich bin
trotzdem sehr gespannt darauf zu sehen
welche fantastischen Entwicklungen die
nächsten Jahrzehnte für uns bereithalten
wird China wie sie es planen ab 2045 die
Eroberung des Weltraums anführen oder
werden die Amerikaner weiterhin die NASA
vorn haben übrigens falls ihr euch mal
direkt mit mir über zum Beispiel dieses
Video hier oder irgendeins der
zukünftigen Videos unterhalten wollt
dann könnt ihr das bald machen denn wir
produzieren seit kurzem live q&a's auf
patreon für alle Unterstützer die den
Rang des Doktors oder höher haben wenn
ihr das noch nicht seid aber ihr gerne
mal wissen wollt wie wir auf videothemen
kommen was vielleicht beim Dreh schief
gelaufen ist oder was es nicht ins Video
geschafft hat dann schaut doch mal auf
patreon.com
/ Dr Watson vorbei ein besonderer Dank
an die Leute die uns schon unterstützen
geht an Jochen Mark und Thomas denn die
haben den Rang des Professors vielen
Dank an Euch für die Unterstützung wir
hoffen ihr seid noch lange mit dabei und
wir hören uns dann im nächsten Q&A
Termin kommt noch schaut einfach mal ab
und zu auf patreon rein wie immer vielen
Dank fürs zuschauen und bleibt neugierig
euer Cedric